i am thrilled to have here in person uh
on the rich eisen show one of the greats
in the world of wrestling wwe superstar
the miz right here on the rich eisen
show hiya brother thanks for having me i
am always awesome i feel like i just got
off a flight i came straight to you dude
you're in three-piece splash i'm in a
three-piece i i flew in this by the way
come on now i flew in this 100 percent
i came straight from the airport right
to you
now i'll be honest um somebody who
dresses like you on a plane would freak
me out you know what i mean you think
yeah like you know i i i dress down and
i feel like do you like i i it all
depends on your moment
i am a pro honestly i fly every single
week we're non-stop we don't have an
off-season like football basketball
baseball you know with wwe we're
non-stop all day every day so if you
have to get off a flight and be in a
three-piece suit you're gonna do it
and you're gonna look good doing it by
the way i mean i'm all business i mean
if you sat next to me you'd be like this
guy means business
i might i may be uplifting for you you
might be like what am i wearing like why
am i wearing this this first of all
if i sat next to you and was one of the
few people who did not know who you were
okay let's just say i have no idea
who you are and i sit next to you i
would think two things one
that i'm being punked okay that there's
something going on like you're about to
jump out of the plane and be in a bond
movie or something like that or two that
you were some sort of businessman
getting ready to go run off to something
i don't know i i would probably ask me
that question like what do you do for a
living what do you do for a living and
then i would probably try to ignore you
who is the last person who asked you
what you did for a
living i mean no it happens every day
like literally
honestly yeah like like whenever like
you know you go into uh a hotel they
always ask what company are you with and
like you have to make up a company
because if i say wwe they're going to be
like oh my god like that and then it's a
conversation and honestly when i go into
a hotel i'm kind of tired i just want to
get to my room i don't want to have the
whole hour conversation about how i'm a
wwe superstar oh what's that like yeah
is it real and it's like it's like come
on like you know give me my key i want
to go to the king-sized bed
you're a king-sized bad guy yeah i'm a
king of course i mean i don't do the two
queens i do
of course of course
i love it fantastic uh and how long are
you are you going to the game or you're
not going i'm i refuse to go to a super
bowl game unless the cleveland browns
are in it
you know what i respect this sort of
thing it's funny you know eric
stonestreet the uh the emmy
award-winning uh actor from modern
family refused to go to a super bowl
until the chiefs were in it and so you
know he's actually gotten to do that
well i plan on doing it next year when
baker is 100
you know this year he had a couple
health problems
and i think that's what set him back i
think next year we will revamp we will
maybe get in the draft uh a wide
receiver uh
a wr1 if you will okay and i think uh
we'll gain some uh some some free agents
and uh i believe miles garrett will be
the defensive player of the year uh i
think people will look at kevin
stefanski as coach of the year and the
team that everyone will be talking about
is the cleveland browns going to the
super bowl and winning the super bowl
with baker mayfield being mvp and the
future franchise quarterback that we all
wanted and knew he would be okay for
those on terrestrial radio uh audrey
just uh uh who just surfed right into
that last soliloquy it is not a stark
raving madman uh it is the miz wwe
superstar talking about
his love of the cleveland browns and how
you will not go to a super bowl unless
the cleveland browns are in it and you
plan on going to next year's in arizona
and seeing the cleveland browns that's
what i plan on doing correctly
that's what i plan on doing and you know
it's funny you know since cincinnati is
in the super bowl this year everyone's
going hey they're from ohio are you
rooting for the cincinnati bengals you
said such a thing everyone and i'm like
no if anything i can't stand that
they're in they were supposed to be in
last place in the afc north they were
supposed to be horrible this year like
they were they were four and 12 last
year yes so i'm thinking okay great the
browns whistles to be number one then it
was gonna be like baltimore and
pittsburgh and you know and then there
was the cincinnati bengals and now the
cincinnati bengals are in the super bowl
if anyone in the afc north is supposed
to be in the super bowl it's the brown
so
no i am not rooting for the bengals the
bengals are going to lose uh the los
angeles rams are going to defeat them
and they're going to slaughter them
because like in the beginning of the
year wasn't the problem with the
cincinnati bengals like the line the
offensive line even at the very last
even in the stages of the victory and uh
victorious and being victorious in the
playoffs yeah and now they're going up
against aaron donald and von miller like
i'm sorry it's just
they were great last week or what was it
last week yeah last week uh
not so much gonna happen for the super
bowl okay so i i will on behalf of those
from the the city of cincinnati please
push back a little bit please push back
okay on behalf of those bengals fans who
are going to be watching this later or
currently right now watching and
screaming uh or listening and throwing
stuff um how do we square odell beckham
jr
being in this super bowl when he
couldn't do anything with the browns how
do we square this you know i i look at
that and i don't know
how it happened like honestly he looks
like a superstar
and he hit any team to choose he could
have chose any team he wanted to go to
and he chose the los angeles rams and he
chose right like the rams lose robert
woods now granted it's a different wide
receiver position yes but he's connected
with stafford he he's he's a big play
type of player and a big moment type of
player and in the super bowl if you
don't think odell beckham jr is going to
lay out and just be absolutely
incredible then i think you're wrong and
i think stafford's probably going to be
mvp if not aaron donald by sacking and
strip sacking and just
just creating a lot of pressure for for
now granted bro has a ton a ton
of just weapons like if you look at his
weapons they're absolutely incredible
but i just don't think that line is
going to be able to do anything his best
weapon could be you know his
pulse you know what i mean like his that
could be his super
weapon that could be making him the nfl
superstar you know and it already has
joe is able to do the unthinkable and
win
the super bowl in his first full year
right he's he's like tom brady like it
reminds me of like oh remember when tom
brady came in and first year he just
kind of took over
it's kind of the way it feels i feel
like uh the miz here on the rich eisen
show again wrestlemania 38 by the way
takes place april second and third at
the home of the dallas cowboys 18t
stadium uh we'll talk uh more about your
los angeles future here uh on the rich
eisen show in a moment so yeah i i if
borrow wins
you're i think you hit on something here
if boro wins the comparisons to brady
will be off the charts because of what
you just said first time in two you know
first he wins one in his first two years
in first four years right exactly just
like tom did and i think the rest of our
days
our days our kids days your
grandchildren's days when you know when
there will be a great episode of miz and
mrs on that uh day um that
we're going to be looking at anybody who
does what burrow might be able to do and
say this is the guy who has a shot
albeit small to catch brady one day
that's how we're going to be looking at
any kid that comes out again if somebody
ever comes out of college and wins it as
a rookie
look out i think that's what is that
i think we do with patrick mahomes a lot
yes we do i think we did it last year
when he went against brady like if he
wins that means he's one step closer
everyone's always going to be compared
to brady because brady is absolute the
epitome of greatness right and so for
every young
you know star coming into the nfl that's
that's that's your goal your goal is to
get there and exceed him but how do you
do it
like
i mean i mean you were just talking
about it like brady retiring is he
really gonna stay retired i don't know
i
i don't think so you do
no
i don't what makes you think that
because when you love something so much
and then you just put it on the shelf
and say no i'm not gonna do this anymore
it's hard it's hard to leave especially
like you watched him this year his ball
velocity wasn't terrible it's not like
his velocity was was was slow like when
you saw payton or ben you were like this
might be his last series the velocity
wasn't as fast as it used to be with
brady he looked great like his ball
velocity was fantastic he was i mean
that last game like he had a tremendous
comeback it's a brady s comeback you
know for him to say like i'm i'm
retiring
i don't know it's just tough to to
believe when you feel like he has more
years in them
well michael irvin as you know was just
here and he said uh essentially it's
he's thinking
it didn't take very long of him just
hanging out at home with wife with with
kids and and just being around with
i just think when you love something so
much and you've dedicated your entire
life to it and you still feel you have
fuel
like fuel in the tank
you're going to want to keep going
you're going to want to keep doing it
until your your body says you can't do
it anymore and watching him play this
year it didn't feel like his body
couldn't do it anymore
maybe his brain is starting to get to a
point where it's like uh maybe i can do
something else but if he found something
else that he loves even more than
football which i don't know maybe it's
the tb12 stuff that he's been doing
right uh but i just i don't see it i got
the miz right here on the rich eisen
show so
wrestlemania is coming to sofie next
year next year this year we're in dallas
it'll be the most stupendous
two-day wrestlemania event that is the
tagline by the way okay yeah i just did
the tagline for you oh i got the tagline
oh i thought that you you were already
being a good company man i'm always
being a good guy i know that you were
given that but you just made that up
right there the most stupendous that is
actually
that is the real tagline believe it or
not it's the most stupendous two-day
wrestlemania event that you're going to
want to see honestly any time uh
wrestlemania comes and this year we're
in dallas april 2nd and 3rd yes it'll be
streaming live on the peacock network
and man i'll tell you what every time
you know i'm always like oh last year's
was so great the year before that was so
great and i'm like how do we top it how
do we top it every year you know we seem
to be able to top it and every year we
create a moment that lasts a lifetime
that people talk about like i had a
match last year against bad bunny who is
one of the biggest uh latin artist
biggest artist music recording artist in
the world and uh honestly that match i
still look at and i go wow that was an
absolutely incredible match for someone
that's never wrestled before he got into
a wwe ring he trained and trained and
trained and dedicated himself
and uh in a tag match he ended up
beating me
you know in my head
with my hand a little bit still mad a
little bit but i can't see that but uh
but man it was it was it was a lot of
fun anytime you get to perform in a
stadium in front of uh like what 80 60
70 80 000 people yeah there's nothing
quite like it you know and if you watch
the super bowl you'll see 100 000 people
in a stadium there's nothing like it
have you ever been in the uh 18t stadium
have you ever been in that one oh yeah
i've been in that one absolutely uh you
know baker was drafted in that building
was he yes he was no i did not know that
he actually held a draft in that what do
you think of baker here's what i think
of baker mayfield i think he has got an
incredible leadership quality to him and
that he has got what they say moxie
i don't know if he has the big game put
the game on my shoulders ability
the fact that and i i i
chris tell him i cape for this man more
than anybody else does baker like it's
his own song well i i because i i first
of all the way he planted the flag on
ohio state
he had me hello as a michigan wolverine
okay so yeah he had me hello right there
and i'm like yeah i and i like that i
also watched him
lose uh unfortunately for him to georgia
in the rose bowl incredible i mean his
performance is incredible and he can do
an uh a whole hell of a lot
i'm just looking at what the hell
happened with odell and i'm like here's
one of the primary weapons
and he's got one of the primary running
backs
and i know he was hurt this year but i'm
wondering what the hell happened that's
what i'm wondering too exactly
don't get like sometimes like honestly
if i'm in a ring and i have a nagging
injury it's in the back of your head the
whole time so maybe when you're trying
to read a defense and trying to get
things going yeah and your shoulders are
out or you're
like you're trying to do your best
totally get it i don't know but then
like okay then does the coach take you
out and it's like no i don't want to
come out because i'm a winner that's
what i want to do and so there's so many
things that go on my brain and go well
why is this why is that and you never
know well and then it doesn't help that
you know first overall picks you draft
them
to put them
[Music]
on the stage
like burrow's done mm-hmm okay and again
and then you see burro do it and you're
like wait a second why that was what you
may feel right this year
that was yeah this year and it was
pretty cool well what weapons did the
browns have how about they had tons of
weapons correct how about jarvis and
odell and
chub and you know when joku who you know
has some incredible physical uh
capabilities
i
i don't know is the only answer when you
say what do i think of baker i think you
can't give him a contract like you know
uh other
of his draft mates got like josh allen
you can't do that yeah but i mean he's
on his fifth year option right now right
so do they draft in the third round
maybe a quarterback as a as a maybe just
maybe
yeah like i'm curious on that like you
do i i don't know because or do you make
a play for aaron rodgers
like everybody i mean look the rams went
all in this year they got stafford right
and they got their their their now they
have all everything they need to
literally well they only say super bowl
they found a willing trading partner to
take the quarterback back i don't think
the packers would take baker mayfield
right you don't think so
no i do not
i do not they they got their own kid
there that's they would be trading they
would be trading away rogers for their
own first round draft choice who has
more contractual control years left than
what baker is and is far less expensive
than what baker would be
i i love him i i do love what he can do
and i think if he does win there he will
be a folk hero and he's well the thing
that keeps saying is like spurgeon win
you know and and couch and we go down
the whole list of everybody that was
there you're already
getting me started you know what i'm
saying so so and he's so much better
than those folks and he has the browns
on so much better footing than those
folks
and then he throws that pic in green bay
you know and again it's easy hurt is he
not
it's not an easy answer clearly yeah to
your question as to what i think of him
but he was drafted in dallas
thank you so much you can think about
appreciation
and then do you have a question for them
is tj i know i'm audibling for you so i
know that you know you are the the uh
wrestling aficionado of the rich eyes
and
me trying to talk to him about the
fantasy football league i'm like i don't
want to talk to him about that like no
he doesn't want to because you know he's
about to you know he he didn't finish
above
us in that league this year so yeah this
is a different league in that league
nathan zagora a friend of our friend
yeah yeah uh but mitch you know with all
the turnaround and things going on in
the wwe a lot of people getting let go
and
just wondering like how what are your
thoughts on that because there seems to
be a lot of people that you could
potentially make some money with and now
they're gone so you know
you know it's it's always tough when
your friends and your colleagues you
know get released but you always wish
for the best for them and uh you just
you do what you do like you just keep
going you know like uh when uh when my
buddy john morrison he got he got
released he was my tag team partner for
a very long time and when he got
released i was like oh man you know but
i know john and i know the type of
person he is and i know he'll succeed in
everything that he does right and so you
always wish the best for them and for me
in wwe like when you go to monday night
raw all right what am i doing how do i
make this something that the live
audience who paid money for their seats
can get something out of this can really
sink their teeth into and you know have
a memory like whenever i see a dad with
it with their with their son or a mom
with their son or daughter you know you
want to create a moment for them so when
10 years down the line hey remember that
time we went to that wwe event and the
miz did this or this superstar did this
that's what you're always looking to
create
so yeah am i am i sad when when people
get released and and you know my buddies
go somewhere somewhere else or do
something else of course
of course but you know it's my job as a
wwe superstar to keep elevating myself
and keeping myself at a certain level to
where i can do the best i possibly can
for the fans out there are you still i
mean season three of miz and mrs
debuting usa network coming up in june
do you i mean are you still cool with
cameras just being everywhere i love it
man
honestly like
doing miz and misses it has brought my
family together like am i the only time
my dad wants to come to la to visit me
he's like are you filming
and it's like
no dad i just want you to come and hang
out with the girls well if you're not
filming i mean i don't i don't know if i
have time to go do that yeah we're
filming i'll be right there it's like
thanks dad appreciate it and this season
like you know my girls are two and a
half and like four now yeah and they're
toddlers and they they literally do not
listen to me like i was just in denver
10 000 people had a microphone they were
all listening to me but i can't get my
two and a half and four-year-old to just
pick up after themselves oh god yeah
welcome
welcome to the world do you think this
is this like and like i i don't know
what to do like i don't want to yell at
them
but i also want them to listen to me yes
so i try to do the whole
you know when when you when you put
something on the ground you need to put
it back so you can clean it up and then
they look at me and they go aha uh-huh
yeah just throw this right there and
this right there oh this water oh this
juice yeah it is stainable yeah i don't
care i don't care here oh you see this
marker let me just paint something for
you on the wall
look at this isn't this amazing it's
incredible dear i love it oh wow it's
amazing keep going please and this will
be stuff that you could show them years
from now yeah when they're not listening
to you on much bigger issues
so cherish these moments cherish these
moments that they don't listen to me
believe it or not
yeah man
that's what i'm telling you
i didn't get this son i'm my dad's best
dad ever for nothing there you go i mean
but uh this this season we actually take
them to they see snow for the first time
that's a big bear yeah and uh they see
snow they went sled riding my daughter
uh monroe four years old right goes up
goes up the first time i'm like she
might be scared you know so i go down
with her and then the next time she's
like i want to go by myself and i'm like
i don't know she's four like i don't
want her to go down by herself and yeah
but in my the
the dad in me is like let her go down
she'll be all right she goes down
amazing fast goes down great she goes
back up there's this one where there's
like it's like goes like this and she's
going towards it and my wife's like i
don't know about that i'm like
let's see what she does
she goes up and goes down and she jumps
high jumps high and it goes right
towards the tree look out and i'm like
oh no and i'm running i'm like no
hits the tree
she falls out
but then she like stands up and she like
cries for a second and i'm like are you
okay she goes i'm okay she grabs the
sled goes back up
up the hill and i went girls are
dominant yes
yes and like i was like i was so upset
like i was like i'm a bad parent am i a
terrible parent for letting her by the
way yes am i a terrible parent for
letting her go up to the and go down the
hill and you know and then hitting and
but then to see her like kind of like
hit hit the tree and then stand up and
say i want to do it again that's yeah
clearly you want somebody to to shake it
off and yeah
throw some dirt on it let's go girls are
dominant there no question about it uh
in terms of also stuff that's coming
your way um i'll call out to mike
hoskins can you put the scrabble board
up that what this is my eight-year-old
this is my eight-year-old she's eight uh
taylor and i were playing scrabble which
is kind of good to
teach them about words and then the
addition
the addition with the how much uh tiles
are worth and whatever do you see what
she spells there i love she had a z and
she spells d's
so i was then caught in a a parenting
moment do i
commend her
for her uh ingenuity
but what did you do i enforced the rules
that dees
is not a word it's a word we could use
thank you miss and we have used
so you would
on a future ms and mrs episode should
you play scrabble with either of your
daughters and she pops out the word deez
by the way on a double word score as
well so this was a
i'm curious with this word out of her
mouth
that's the one thing like does she know
the next word well she does know that if
she had an nut uh she could have played
it uh off the z yes and gotten a double
letter on the end
uh but me this was right here this was a
24 point swing of me taking that off the
board i was like raw i mean you guys
i mean that's the one thing
i was like oh isn't that nice she's a
huge wwe fan she watches me every monday
night on raw i'm surprised she didn't
use miz in there or something
that is funny there isn't there are two
eyes and mike the miz everybody there
are two eyes but no it was dees that i
was calling her attention
that's parenting moments that just
curveballs come you have no idea where
they're coming from man and you gotta
say nothing for the fences but sometimes
you just miss
thank god
i've been missing a lot but i'll tell
you what i'm doing my best my wife is
like the best mother ever like
she just knows what to do when to do it
how to do it and it's it's crazy to
watch her in motion and yeah and
watching how she does everything and
then also balancing work because she's
with me on raw you know so bouncing work
and being a great parent i mean it's
just
that's that's the life of what we live
lead and and and that's what you see on
ms and misses just us it's real it's
like it's us being the best parents we
could possibly be but also
having work like you you want to be
great at your job as well well that's
what you want to teach your kids like
that's exactly find a job that you love
and do the best you possibly can at it
you you guys are mirroring the work
ethic and you work your ass off man and
you've worked your ass off to get where
you are and get in that beautiful
three-piece suit and hey i'm ready to
run if you ever need me to sprint by the
way i was getting invited last year to
sofi like to do your draft running i was
like i was watching i was like oh man
this year
are you kidding me the planning is in
stock
you know what i do uh every uh every i
don't know how are you running
i'll bring i'll bring my most expensive
suit to run in you kidding me
i might run by louboutins yeah but
that's my it's but that's my thing
you don't do three people all right then
i won't do the suit then i'll i'll bring
some i'll bring i'll ruin my trunks
i will run in my trunks how about that
in my in my wwe you know wrestlemania
here that's what i love
about that
actually challenge so there's a there's
a there's you're so kind by the way
you're always very supportive there's a
woman that uh in wwe named bianca
bel-air who is called
she's the best at everything and she was
a huge track star and i actually said to
her i said look do you think i could
beat you in a race if i have running
shoes on and you have wrestling boots on
yeah she said no doubt my mind and it
wasn't even like she didn't think about
it and that's what that's what kind of
made me go oh really like she didn't
think about it she goes no doubt my mind
so i went to the entire wwe locker room
i go bianca belair has wrestling boots
on i have running shoes on who wins in a
race and everyone without there was not
one person that had my back everyone
just goes bianca butler will kill you
there's no way there's no way in
wrestling boots and i have running shoes
on yeah that she could beat me in a race
did you race
i'm telling you that maybe this is what
needs to be done as part of ron
richardson she is wrestling bhutan okay
she's a track star and i would rather
she's a track star
you provide the bianca bel-air she
provides the boots and we both lose to
her and i provide the stadium
how does that sound and the challenge
and the charity there we go there we go
saint jude's let's go let's do it
exactly and you're so kind of kid always
at mike the miz twitter and instagram ms
and mrs debuting on usa network in 2022
and then wrestlemania 38 in the home of
the cowboys the jones mahal april 2nd
and 3rd right here on peacock great to
see you brother good to see you you're
the man mike the miz right here on the
rich eisen show hey you watched all the
way to the end thanks for that watch
more right here